hi I'm Evan Carmichael and today's one
minute monday is hustle if you have a
dream if you have a goal if there's
people who you need to connect with the
help you move closer to accomplishing
your vision then hustle every single day
you need to take action to get closer to
accomplishing your dream here's a quick
story for you so I'm an investor in a
company called Toronto dance salsa and
we teach people how to dance salsa and I
actually teach one of the classes that's
the most advanced class once a week and
at the end of my class was last night
there in my class I see this guy
standing outside with a big smile on his
face and he comes in and he says Evan
can I talk to you and I said sure I'm
assuming he has some kind of dance
related question but no jaan wants to
pitch me on on his mobile application
software company and wanted my feedback
on how to get his business off the
ground he apparently found out about me
fall on his friends and he wrote to me
on email and I guess I didn't respond to
him and and he wanted a chance to come
have coffee with me asked him about his
business now I am NOT suggesting
stalking people don't go stalking me but
I do admire the hustle and so it gave
him a link to my schedule and right away
he wanting book the time and I'm gonna
be chatting with him sometime in the
next month about about his business and
helping him grow you gotta hustle you
got to be like yeah you got to get out
there and if there's people who you need
to connect worth over the things that
you need to do every day take one small
action at least to get your business off
the ground you need to take some step
every single day to move closer to your
dream and those small steps will add up
to big things you got to stay on your
hustle belief don't forget to check out
my newsletter click the link below hi
i'm jason j reyez fonseka raza online
com and i want to say Evan Carmichael's
newsletter is consistent fun inspiring
and XD only newsletter i prioritize and
look forward to period